i'm giving away 10 copies of my book
[Music]
what's up believe nation i'm excited i
got all those books that i have that i
need to figure what to do with and my
first plane is i'm going to give away 10
of them that's one box 10 of them to you
guys I want to see something special so
here's the rules here's what I want to
do I'm going to give away 10 bucks I'm
going to sign them I'm going to put a
special message in each of the books so
these will be one of a kind hardcover
signed special message book special
message book I say the right special
special message book for you guys in or
do a giveaway contest I'm super pumped
on it what I want you guys to do is make
a tribute using your art to the book I
want you to pay tribute to the book in
some way using your art so if you're a
youtuber make a video about the book if
you are an artist draw the book if
you're a singer sing something about the
book if you're a graphic designer make a
beautiful graphic about the book if you
are a coder program something about the
book whatever it is whatever your art is
I love art I want you to funnel your art
and creative talents to make some kind
of tribute to the book I want to see
that the deadline is going to be the end
of the year it's got to be in before
december 31st you can link it up in the
comments below put a link to whatever
the resources if it's to a YouTube video
if it's to a web page whatever put a
link down in the comments so we can
track it I don't know if I'm going to
judge or I'll leave it open to the to
you guys to judge or some kind of
combination I haven't figured out those
details yet but I am so pumped I can't
wait to give away 10 copies I want to
see what kind of art you guys can create
I'm confident that the believe nation
has some amazingly talented
entrepreneurs we're going to pour some
love and creativity into making an
amazing tribute for the book link it up
below you have until the end of the year
I want to see it a personalized sign
with a message copy from me right to
your mailbox let's do it guys send it
down I'm curious to find out all right
with that excitement behind this let me
get to the questions and comes at you
hide from last week's video first up
rose 10 remember when Oprah and Eckhart
Tolle did a worldwide live webinar 10
weeks one chapter week live Q&A that
would be awesome Evan so rose s that's
the plan i haven't announced the dates
for it but i'm going to do the seven
chapters in the book there's a
conclusion into a bunch of other stuff
but seven chapters in the book and i'm
going to do a seven-week program for
free probably monday afternoons it's
where my usual book time by book video
slot is and yeah that may continue maybe
i'll bring on special guest to talk
about their one word maybe i'll bring on
people from who bought the book and have
questions i don't know what to do like
after the seven maybe we repeat it again
the people weren't able to join the
first time but for sure at least once
we're going to go through one chapter
per week for seven weeks live youtube
hangout on air to have me answer
whatever questions you have about the
book and that chapter because i really
want to make sure that you are getting
results that you know the money you
invested is a is a solid return and that
you're you're making the big change and
impact on your life it's probably gonna
be in the new year and as soon as i have
the details i will let you know next up
another one from rose finally got the
book today whoo I always leave over a
book from front to back to see of one
its user-friendly too easy on the eyes
and three draws me in so yes yes yes I
love it I love it I love it I've always
wanted to do an alternative book club
this may be a great start
congratulations Rose thank you for the
love i really feel it and super excited
to have you as part of the book club
when we put it up next up dr phoenix
congrats heaven got my book and i'm
loving the read thumbs up thumbs up dr
phoenix feeling the love thank you
fernando almost 500 k congrats man I
appreciate that Fernando by the time
this goes up it probably will be 500k
already I film on Wednesdays and this
book series comes out on Monday so i
probably will hit I probably will pass
500,000 by Thursday which is tomorrow
for me so yeah it's been it's been a fun
ride I don't know
some kind of celebration or not really
won millions the next milestone for me
so this is just another another step to
get in there but yeah thank you for the
love of support for all you guys for
subscribe to the channel for sharing the
videos for leaving comments or being
part of belief nation I love it it fuels
me gives me energy and excited to get to
that next half a million to get to the
million mark big party get 1 million
I'll need your ideas when we get there
it's coming I don't know what to do yet
but I'll tap you guys up next up Chris
saber got the book recently at my local
bookstore I love the gold wording on the
art cover I'm glad you're feeling that
the art the cover is one of the things
that I was not a huge fan of honestly
feel like it could have been way way way
better but we were short on time and and
me I didn't understand the the cycle how
long it took to do artwork on the cover
and they basically told me yeah you have
like one week to make a decision on this
and anyway so I'm glad you like it my
publisher and my agent both liked it i'm
not a huge fan but i love the content of
the book so i'm glad that though you
side with my agent publisher and love
the cover that that that gets me pumped
Mike how can I get your book in Nigeria
thank you Mike for the question there is
a website that we've linked up before is
a book depository something like that
will link it up here right here this is
it go check that out it ships anywhere
in the world otherwise looking at your
typical websites amazon that stuff i
don't know if it's any local if you got
you know i want to see I want to see
pictures of the book in different cities
so what if you're from a different city
I want a landmark like Here I am in st.
Louis with the arch with the book I'd
love to see some of those coming whether
you post it on Twitter or Facebook or
whatever send me a link I would sue I'm
gonna be super pumped to see the book in
different cities in different countries
so for those you bought the book please
put it out there i'm curious to see
those valentin man you're such a hard
worker definitely gonna read the book
greetings from the other end of the
world bulgaria you got to work hard you
gotta work hard on the thing that you
love to do I don't see this as work you
know i look forward to video day i look
forward to talking you guys
it's it's one of my favorite parts of
the week and you know Jerry Seinfeld
doing the torture that you enjoy I love
this stuff I'm a look at the work you do
and say that's crazy that's torture I
never want to do it you can look at my
thing and say man I could never keep up
with Evan that's okay don't do me do you
and work hard hard hard at it because
you got one life you got to make it
count next up tomorrow hey Evan I know
youtube and facebook is your media
outlet twitter twitter twitter twitter
but please consider using Instagram live
instagram i haven't i don't know i
haven't gotten in the Instagram mostly
because it's all on the phone and i
don't really use a phone if there was a
desktop way to do it I'd probably way
more into it but i don't i use a phone
as a tablet but i don't use it as a
phone so instagram and snapchat I've
never been my thing because it's too
mobile but I appreciate the love and if
it keeps coming in maybe I'll look at it
again by the way I thought I had it
planned out who to get my books to but
now I feel like I'm struggling with who
will really value the information I feel
you're there just alone your videos have
helped me get through running my second
company now the book is going to help me
take it to another level once i reread
it you've already read it amazing reread
it hashtag believe nation all the way I
feel like I need a hoodie would believe
on it for more inspiration hope you're
killing it with the sales Tam cam yeah
people been asking about the believe
hoodie not for sale anywhere the
t-shirts arguing to believe t-shirt and
you can get the the rebel t-shirt with
all the words on it but I haven't done
the hoodie I don't know maybe maybe at
some point if you guys can recommend a
good hoodie provider I don't want I
don't want crap to ship out and I use
teespring I think teespring for the
t-shirts and they don't have hoodies as
far as i know so maybe they do maybe
she'll look into it believe hoodies i'm
a fan it's winter it's Canada I need my
hoodie stay warm pitch cakes congrats
Evan so well deserve and I can't wait to
get your ebook now that my new kindle is
on the way xmas present to myself yay i
love that you got yourself a christmas
present and i love that my book is one
of the things you're going to reward
yourself with so thank you for that love
and let me know what you think about the
book once you do get it Jessica officer
I'm in law school but when i was at
Purdue it's an under
every year the school had a book they
read it's a must read English majors
take it seriously you can talk to
university dean of students and make the
book deal I with the University that's a
super cool idea I need to I would need
to find a way to leverage that how do
you how do i I kinda want to be making
calls to University of Dean's one at a
time I need to find an association or
something to be able to reach everybody
at once to make the time worth it but
you're putting your putting something in
my head there I appreciate the love next
up best you Pro be more concerned with
the marriage than the wedding day love
it that's right i mean the wedding they
still important again I caveat that I
don't celebrate enough celebration is
important but be more concerned about
the long-term celebration than just that
one day because that one day is small in
the big scheme of things this applies in
so many situations I finally picked up
my copy from ship me today there's a
book review coming to best you pros
youtube channel soon I appreciate that
man I found my one word by just reading
the chapter synopsis that you sent
hashtag persist I think we believe
nation can celebrate with a video
detailing our major takeaway from the
book then create a video with all the
best ones you can send a copy to
participants but they have to give it to
someone that people can then post a
video with their major takeaways I love
the video with the major takeaway idea
for those of you especially who are
youtubers who are more comfortable in
front of the camera yeah that's like if
if if ten of you want to make a video
with your major takeaway I will mash all
of those together and say here are the
10 takeaways from 10 of my readers and
I'll put that up as a standalone video
and help you guys promote your channel
to my audience I would be happy to do
that if you guys want to do one takeaway
each maybe that's a future challenge or
if you guys want to take me up on it
like ASAP and get going first 10 put it
down the links and and we'll get going
on it but don't forget the main
challenge guys don't get distracted from
the main challenge the tribute to the
book using your art form I want to see
it I want to sign a copy with a
customized message I want to send it to
you enter today before the end of the
year I want to see it guys express your
art put it down there
and last stop Antoine congrats having
long time no see great to see you
Antoine thanks for tweeting out the book
appreciate it man I started reading your
book a few days ago and i love the
wisdom and the knowledge yes well my
voice cracked yes Antoine yes thank you
for putting the work happy face I didn't
celebrate any specific way from my own
book I was already on to the next one
whatever you do I'll do my best to drop
by Toronto I love the city take care
Antoine Sam Montreal about a five hour
drive from Toronto yeah man i'd love to
see you come join me for Joe me for
video let's do something and thank you
for the love with the book that's it for
today guys appreciate all the support
all the love it's been a crazy couple
weeks launching this book and I'm so
pumped to see the impact that the book
has so back to the topic back to the big
humongous challenge to express your
artistic creativity giving away 10 bucks
signed personalized customized from my
hands to the mailbox to your door
special book express an artistic tribute
to the book a song a program a design a
video whatever it is that you do a dance
whatever it is that you do poor artistic
love to make a tribute I almost video a
tribute to the book i'm going to pick
the top 10 and you guys get the
autograph customized personalized
amazing allies believe believeth sighs
book in your hands enter now you got
until the end of the year link it up in
the comments and we're going to pick our
best 10 thank you guys for watching I
really appreciate the love I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon